ce lundi matin c'est illinois
réfléchissent à la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie de demain par petits
groupes ils élaborent des idées au sein
de ce tout premier atelier collaboratif
organisé par la cpam des yvelines
moi je suis d'un tempérament un peu
râleur et je me suis dit plutôt que de
râler dans mon coin et j'ai très
curieuse aussi donc ça me samsam
intéressés vivement d'aller donner mon
avis chaque groupe présente ensuite son
idée aux autres avant de voter pour la
plus convaincante saison le 3d remporté
ces élections
l'idée elle va être présenté en comité
de direction dans la semaine ou la
semaine suivante
une étude de faisabilité sera fait
et enfin un retour aux participants pour
leur dire voilà ce qu'il en a été de la
suite de l'idée
les participants se sont largement
impliqués il quitte l'atelier en se
sentant acteurs d'un changement sans
oublier de laisser leurs avis nous on
nous a dit qu'elle serait remonté la
direction
la caisse primaire d'assurance maladie
et on est prêt à suivre de voir ce qui
se passe et on aimerait en effet voir
comment dans le temps ça va pouvoir être
mis en oeuvre ou en tout cas inspiré des
aspects qui sont mis en oeuvre par la
cpi l'atelier il aa permis quand même de
rencontrer beaucoup de personnes et donc
la caisse à ces problèmes
les assurés ont leurs problèmes et en
échangeant en partageant toutes les
idées dont je pense qu'on améliore
beaucoup de la relation un premier
atelier test pour la cpam des yvelines
qui au vu des main levée semble avoir
convaincu ses participants volontaires